Mr Simpson let me outline the gastric
bypass surgery procedure for you okay we
put the band around your stomach so that
no solid food may enter well that's not
really gastric bypass that's like a
sleeve you see just like so that there
was a cow and a pretzel very very
serious operation you should only
undergo it as a last resort well that's
absolutely true for a gastric bypass
they're done laparoscopically now which
decreases healing time complication rate
Etc but basically you make the stomach
into like a really small pouch reconnect
the GI tract in a way where you decrease
the amount of absorption of food but the
interesting part about bariatric surgery
why we recommend it it's really the only
form of lasting weight loss that we have
really good evidence for other ways in
which people lose weight five to ten
years later doesn't seem to be as
effective they seem to put that weight
back on but with bariatric surgery the
results seem to hold in a decent amount
of the cases kids your daddy he
underwent a special procedure so he can
be more attractive to your mother well I
hope you're not doing it just to be more
attractive you're doing it for all the
health benefits welcome home Marge you
remembered I like romance do you like
guys who are
attractive
homie you look good all for you baby
he looks like the mannequins in the
men's clothing stores that you think the
suit fits perfectly or the pea coat fits
perfectly and in the back they're all
like pinned and they'll never look like
that on your body what are you hiding
from me is it chocolate uh it used to be
whoa those buns are popping wait fresh
how did those things oh he pulled into
the front doctor I'm embarrassed to show
my body to my wife and it's all because
of your surgery you want me to unstable
your stomach you give it a staple
remover out I want you to give me every
other surgery you have so I can look
good and can you call it an aortic valve
replacement so my insurance will cover
it no problem it's insurance fraud okay
someone order a super stud
my implants feel itchy yes I was out the
silicone rubber so I used rolled up
socks
he's a monster pitchforks everyone
you know we're laughing at this but you
know there's been this trend of
individuals who've been injecting into
their muscles Synthol in order for
themselves to look huge and they've been
getting popular on Tick Tock and
recently one of the biggest names who
who we've actually reacted to on this
channel recently lost his life best
wishes to his family
I gotta be honest with you you better
not make me cry cause I don't know where
my tear ducts are anymore I appreciate
you trying to become more attractive for
me but the truth is I'm way too
successful for you now I'm getting me a
trophy husband
there were steer ducks went sisters are
doing it for themselves
oh no it's Dad
foreign
okay you don't have to use defib paddles
uh for back injury I hope that goes
without saying oh it's good for the
batteries now I'm afraid your son has
cracked his coccyx based on the
mechanism of injury which is a big part
of what we do in healthcare we look at
how the injury happened in fact on
professional sports Sidelines when you
work as a team doctor one of the doctors
usually runs over to the replay Booth to
try to understand exactly how the injury
occurred because that gives us the most
amount of information about that injury
with what I saw happen there on the fall
in the bowling ball didn't look like it
happened on the coccyx the way we
diagnose obviously one of these
fractures is through an x-ray but just
general pain of the coccyx is called
coccydynia for you to know how long will
it take to recover they usually take
weeks sometimes even months for the
paint to fully go away and the pain
initially is terrible you have to get
one of those little Donuts to take the
pressure off the middle portion of your
spine when you're seated and really just
sit on your ischial tuberosities and
actually a lot of patients start taking
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory stories
like Advil leave when they get pained
after a broken tailbone but some
evidence has actually shown that taking
non-steroidal anti-inflammatories can
lead to poor fracture healing for my
patients I try Tylenol if you need
something stronger Tramadol is an option
people really do request something
stronger I say lidocaine patch I love
those
but check his bowl that's what you do
chest compressions to a BG song yeah
love but you should check if he's alive
first
your love are you sure it wasn't that
stand alone Wrong song bro really need
to learn cause we're living in yeah and
his positioning is not great he want to
be on the side he want to be doing it
two inches deep breaking us down see if
he's alive you got to stop doing the
chest compression
the purpose of doing the chest
compressions is to circulate the blood
because the heart has stopped if a
person's talking their heart's beating
our top story today Springfield will
experience a rare total eclipse of the
Sun a solar eclipse is like a woman
breastfeeding in a restaurant it's free
it's beautiful but under no
circumstances should you look at it you
don't want to stare at an eclipse I mean
you don't want to look at the sun period
because you could damage part of your
eye known as the retina develop
something known as solar retinopathy
where you actually burn a part of your
retina this can happen with even a short
period of time looking at an eclipse and
I know people like if it's a total
eclipse it blocks out the sun fully
where you're going to get damaged well
guess what it's only a total eclipse for
a short period of time when it starts
moving it's only a partial clip that's
when the damage occurs and really the
damage happens on the point Point known
as a fovea where you lose the central
vision and then you get disorientation
and color changes all of that okay
people we've hit
[Music]
no I'm gonna see it first yeah looking
through a pinhole you'll get to see the
whole thing happening without the damage
happening to your eye and also people
think oh if I just wear sunglasses I'll
be fine that doesn't actually protect
you unless there are a special type of
sunglasses my space toy
oh it's okay homie bro it's a paper
towel roll you can have my viewer but
Mom you'll miss the eclipse there'll be
another one in North Yemen in 2027.
we'll be talking about this together for
years
no don't look it's
it's not that quick but there's no safe
amount of time that we would say oh you
can look at it not Marge your eyes must
stay completely covered for two full
weeks there's actually no real treatment
for solar retinopathy but you still want
to go see an ophthalmologist if you were
to damage your eyes
volatile injury income me boy I tried
ordering you I tried punishing you and
God help me I even tried reasoning with
you and the only thing left for me to do
is jump The Gorge myself
and you'll never make it don't you think
I know that don't do it I won't jump
anymore I promise oh well thank God you
know boy I don't think I've ever felt
this close to you as I do right
[Music]
cervical neck fracture see collar now
no no no
[Music]
no
why not just airlift him all the way to
the hospital the fact that he's
surviving thousand foot falls makes me
want to study his body
reactor studio and I might explode you
just sit back and relax oh dear God this
man's kidneys have exploded all right
they don't explode but what you can
develop is hydronephrosis your bladder
is more likely to release and allow the
urine to come out than your kidneys are
to explode and by not going to pee when
you want to go you can actually cause
like that urinary stasis to continue and
develop infections in that area yeah
that's what happens when you get older
it's one of those Natural Things
beautiful in its way uh actually his
kidneys were fine yesterday when he had
his annual checkup I love that he's
having x-rays showing the kidneys as the
same visual as the spine no bones and
kidneys do not light up the same look at
any real X-Ray I don't feel so good well
yeah you need to be on dialysis sir or
get a kidney transplant stacked can't
live without a kidney come on Duck
there's got to be something I can do to
help my dad well you could give him a
kidney a kidney
okay fine you see the waiting list for a
kidney is very long yeah an America on
average if you are on the donor list to
get a kidney usually takes a few years
three to five years oh thank you son
I'll take the left one it's good and
springy though the right one's not
without its charge you really can't feel
the kidneys like that and the fact that
he has no kidneys and he's still moving
around is sus well I gotta hand it to
your Homer you're really Brave to go
through with this operation it's not an
operation Mo the doctor says it's just a
procedure no no no making polenta that's
a procedure you're talking about deadly
life-threatening surgery yeah no it's
not deadly but it's definitely a risk
and you have to get pre-operative
clearances by Family Medicine doctor
that's what I would do and what's
interesting is when you put in a kidney
you don't put it in the back you put it
in the front in the lower abdomen the
point is with only one kidney you won't
be able to drink yourself stupid no more
I mean you still can drink alcohol that
the idea is that you're at a much higher
risk because you don't have a backup
kidney so you want to respect that
kidney meaning you don't want to overuse
non-steroidal anti-inflammatories you
don't want to consume nephrotoxic
substances you want to make sure that
you're always well hydrated you feel me
plus they'll put down one of those organ
donors sucker lists everybody who wants
an eyeball or a spine or a vestigial
tail will be after you I'm an organ
donor proud organ donor why aren't you
change your license today can you
imagine you could be one of the lucky
people that gets one of my organs
just saying that's like better than
merch hey I got a Dr Mike Shirt By the
way you can get those down below but hey
I got Dr Mike's eyeball I win
um
from today Dan can I have fun with my
joke God by the way I gotta dispel that
rumor that people think that if they get
into an accident or they're sick that if
you go to the emergency room and they
see you're an organ owner they don't
take good care of you that's absolutely
false Zero have I ever heard of that and
if I did don't you think I probably
would not make myself an organ donor
What If instead of donating one of my
old worn out kidneys I gave grandpa that
artificial kidney I invented oh Homer
that was just a beer can with a whistle
glue to it but remember why you're doing
this it's for your father the man who
raised you and nurtured you you know
it's interesting when you get a renal
transplant you end up having to take
immunosuppressant medications for the
rest of your life but still the evidence
looks like getting the kidney transplant
you live a longer life than someone who
has to undergo dialysis multiple days of
the week and odds are you'll have a
higher quality of life because you don't
have to always go for dialysis I love
you son I love you Dad
now don't you fellas worry this will all
be over uh what's there with Justin
Bieber's girlfriend Selena Gomez had a
kidney transplant from her friend right
she rings a bell
also that was like 10 years ago excuse
me I'm still mourning the loss of that
relationship what the
we gotta get rid of that window don't
worry about old Grandpa I'm going to a
better place I just don't understand why
they can't put them on dialysis we have
a lot of patients in the United States
who are considered end-stage renal
disease they go on dialysis and they
don't live a typically normal life they
have a lower quality of life because
they have to be tied to the dialysis
center but
they're alive I'm sorry dude the way I
behaved was shameful I guess fear made
me run away
but love made me come back bless your
son now Homer this may sting just a tiny
bit but
oh shut up
he's waking up oh homie I'm so glad
you're all right
hey while we were setting your broken
bones and putting your blood back in we
helped ourselves to a kidney and gave it
to your father you don't help yourself
to a kidney you usually have to sign off
on that one
you know it's pretty dark in in some
countries they actually sell organs
that's like a well-known black market
for organ trade I know you're a little
peeved at Grandpa dad but you've done a
wonderful thing yes you've shortened
your life significantly so someone else
can have a slight experience he didn't
shorten his life significantly come on
Marge I don't need two kidneys I have
everything I need right here hmm
you're tickling me here's what happens
when you eat McDonald's and only
McDonald's for 30 days click here to
check that out and as always stay happy
and healthy
now while eating McDonald's
[Music]